- All right y'all, we're back and I'm here
with the lovely Amy Adams, give it up!
(mimics DJ air horn)
(audience claps and cheers)
In honor of her awesome
and creepy Netflix movie,
The Woman in the Window, it's time to play
What's Creepin' Up On Me?
♪ What's creepin' up on me? ♪
- (laughs) Get it, Jessi!
So Amy and I each have screens behind us
but we can't see what's
in our own screens.
So we'll give each other
clues about what's creeping up
without saying the name of what it is.
If we can correctly guess 10 things
in two rounds together,
this is a team effort, Amy, okay?
- We can do this.
- The audience will win
a cool prize.
I think we got this, you ready?
- Okay, yeah, I gotta get focused here.
- All right, all right, okay,
so you're gonna give
me clues first, ready?
And go!
- Yes.
Okay, it runs on a track.
- An athlete?
- It says choo-choo.
- Oh, oh, a train!
(bell dings)
- Yes ma'am.
Oh, this is terrifying.
Pennywise is one of these--
- Balloon? It?
- They're in the circus.
- It? Balloon clown!
- Clown!
(bell dings)
- Yes.
Oh, she's our favorite
person, she taught me to knit.
- Meryl Streep!
(bell dings)
(Amy exclaims)
- Goodness, okay,
so E.T. came out of one of
these, there's sightings--
- Spaceship!
- They're up in the sky.
(bell dings)
- Oh, okay, this lays eggs--
- Chicken!
- Some people are--
(bell dings)
Yeah.
Oh, Jurassic Park, this
is the villain, scary.
- Dinosaur!
(bell dings)
- Oh! (stutters)
You're on things and you're
being pulled by a boat,
the Go-Go's do this in
one of their videos.
- What? Tube! Tubing!
(bell dings three times)
(triumphant music)
Oh, time is up, what was it?
- Water-skiing, sorry.
- Water, oh god, I'm an idiot.
I don't water-ski, we tube, sorry.
- All I could think of is the Go-Go's.
And I'm like, "The Go-Go's!"
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
- That was the most, that's awesome!
We already got six, we only
need you to get four, Amy!
(audience cheers)
You're amazing!
So I'm giving clues now, let's do this.
We only need four. Ready, and go!
Oh, The Walking Dead?
- Zombies.
- Yeah!
(buzzer sounds)
Wait, what? Oh, Egypt!
They would, there was a process--
- Oh, mummies!
(bell dings)
- Sorry, sorry, I thought it was a zombie.
- That's okay.
- Jaws!
- A shark.
(bell dings)
- Talladega Nights, he
was in it, so were you.
- Will Ferrell.
(bell dings)
- (laughs) Oh wait, we already
said this one, Walking Dead!
- Mummy.
- No, no, before,
the one before!
- Oh, zombie!
(bell dings)
- (cheers) We did it!
(audience claps and cheers)
Oh my gosh, I can't believe
mummy ended up being one.
I thought it was--
I mean zombie, I thought
it was a zombie, whatever.
Okay, so we got 10 correct,
which means we're amazing,
let's lead with that.
(audience cheers)
And everybody's a winner today,
so this is for everyone
in the house seats,
Monarch Reign swimwear
is meticulously crafted
in New York City with high quality fabrics
and sustainable materials.
Their swimwear is as unique and beautiful
as the women wearing them.
I have a couple, I love them.
Just in time for summer you're all getting
a $300 Monarch Reign gift card!
(Kelly imitates DJ air horn)
(audience claps and cheers)
They're really cute
swimsuits, no joke. I own two.
Thank you for dropping by, Amy.
I love you, even more now!
- Thank you so much, it's so nice
to get to spend this time
with you, sincerely, thanks.
- Absolutely, I can't wait for
one day you're here in person
'cause I really do wanna
sing with you, okay (laughs)
- I thought, I was like, oh you can't wait
to come over to my back
room and do some karaoke
but you're also invited here.
- Hey, I will do that,
that's a nice appetizer
for what's to come, I
will totally come over
and do that (laughs)
- Absolutely.
When we open up, all right.
- Or we might find your husband in there
just jamming by himself
which is the best part.
- He's like, "I programmed about 50 songs
so you can come back in two hours."
- All right, well
everybody, Amy's new movie,
The Woman in the Window is now on Netflix,
y'all have to watch it, it's
so trippy, it's so good.